merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin vous êtes ancienne
ministre évidemment on vous présente
plus hauteur de ce livre
682 jours c'est d'oserions c'est le
récit de votre passage au ministère de
la Culture on va longuement parler mais
d'abord je voulais savoir pourquoi ce
bandeau de votre éditeur le bal des
hypocrites c'est un peu le souscrit de
votre livre pourquoi parce que dans ces
682 jours qui ont été magnifiques qui
pour moi resteront vraiment une parcelle
brillante de mon exercice politique j'ai
rencontré beaucoup de doubles langages
et finalement double langage chez les
artistes double langage chez les élus
double langage chez les syndicats mais
finalement c'était un peu logique parce
que il y avait tellement de troubles
devant la fermeture des lieux de culture
devant les difficultés rencontrées par
les uns et les autres devant cette
horrible épidémie covidaire qui est là
ce n'est pas n'est pas terminé que
finalement il y a beaucoup de tendresse
aussi dans ce livre ouais évidemment on
va en parler 680 jours en plein covid
vous nous l'avez dit puisque votre
passage au ministère de la Culture a été
marqué par cette pandémie est-ce qu'avec
le recul vous répondriez la même chose à
Jean Castex quand il vous a passé ce
fameux coup de fil pour vous dire qu'il
souhaitait vous nommer les cultures je
crois que oui
c'est vrai que
en temps normal je leur ai répondu non à
Jean Castex je suis pas une carrière à
mon âge une carrière politique au
contraire j'avais beaucoup de choses que
j'ai effectuais aussi bien dans le cadre
de mes actions humanitaires que dans mes
fonctions d'éditorialiste mais j'aime
bien les challenges et je crois que je
répondrai oui à nouveau si la situation
était impossible et si vite parce que là
vous allez c'est 10 secondes
je suis une vieille bête politique et je
sais aussi que quand on constitue un
gouvernement écoutez je vais réfléchir
pendant 15 jours non ça se fait pas
comme ça mais je dis souvent
ah mais si on vous demandait quelque
chose je dis je suis comme un vieux
soldat qui a abandonné son fusil mais
qu'il laisse dans l'armoire et qu'il
regarde tous les matins s'il est en état
de marche le covid a été pour vous
est-ce que ça a été une occasion de
manquer finalement d'imprimer votre
marque au ministère de la Culture je
pense pas que ce soit une occasion
manquée d'abord parce que effectivement
il y a un certain nombre de défis qui
sont posés à la culture j'ai posé
quelques je dirais
un peu de fondation mais d'abord je n'en
ai pas eu le temps la durée de vie des
des ministres de la Culture est assez
brève en général c'est moins de 2 ans
c'est difficile de mener une action de
fond puis l'urgence imposait de de
sauver le monde de la culture
effectivement c'était pas le temps de
poser des réformes de fonds qui sont
absolument nécessaires révolution
écologique révolution numérique
révolution de la gouvernance révolution
site question sociétale comme l'égalité
homme-femme comme la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes la
question de la diversité dans le monde
de la culture mais néanmoins malgré les
difficultés de la crise covidaire on a
avancé sur ces dossiers et maintenant
maintenant le relais est à ma successeur
qu'est-ce qu'on retiendra de vous comme
la culture qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on retienne de vous comme les autres
la culture je veux qu'on retienne de moi
d'abord ce que j'ai dit en arrivant au
ministère je serai la ministre des art
c'est des territoires on va revenir sur
cette phrase et la ministre des artistes
je pense que j'ai sauvé la culture dans
cette crise covidaire et des territoires
qui sont venus vous voir de manière un
peu vénante pour se plaindre de la
manière dont ils ont été traités pendant
cette période je leur ai pardonné parce
qu'il y avait beaucoup de souffrance
quand on est privé de son public et ça a
amené parfois des réflexions
inappropriées je les raconte avec qui
m'ont fait d'autant fait du mal ça vous
a touché j'ai une peau de crocodile au
bout de tous ces années mais qui m'ont
fait du mal oui je l'ai ressenti comme
une injustice mais en même temps j'ai
compris j'étais partagé parce que je
connaissais cette souffrance qui était
qui était intime et c'est tout à fait
normal de la même ils se sont pas rendus
se rendent pas compte de la chance
qu'ils ont d'être en France ou le
secteur a quand même été beaucoup aidé
ah ça c'est tout à fait l'effet sont
têtus c'est la France qui a le plus
soutenu ses artistes et d'ailleurs
beaucoup maintenant le disent parce que
ils ont repris les contacts par exemple
avec les artistes étrangers quand la
cantatrice québécois dit au micro de
France Musique vous vous rendez pas
comment vous les Français vous vivez
dans un pays de cocagne il vous êtes
toujours en train de vous plaindre
si vous en parler dans votre livre on va
revenir sur cette phrase mais d'abord
dans ce livre on retrouve votre
franc-parler on retrouve du Roselyne
Bachelot vous n'hésitez pas à tacler
votre ancienne famille politique les LR
on peut en parler avec sévérité mais
avec tendresse en même temps et surtout
je défends Valérie Pécresse parce que
elle a rencontré ses pires ennemis à
l'intérieur de sa famille politique mais
c'est souvent comme ça on va on va y
revenir vos anciens collègues du
gouvernement aussi certains prennent
pour leur garde et même Emmanuel Macron
alors Emmanuel Macron il a aussi droit
avec une tendresse infinie un regard sur
le serpent câble
de la jungle vous dites il n'a pas
toujours l'attitude qu'on attend d'un
Président
c'est très étonnant parce que
j'ai servi trois présidents de la
République Jacques Chirac Nicolas
Sarkozy et
Emmanuel Macron et c'est vrai que lors
de l'entretien préliminaire qu'on a avec
le président de la République en général
le président de la République vous dit
vous êtes ministre de l'écologie avec
Jacques Chirac de la santé avec Nicolas
Sarkozy et de la culture avec Emmanuel
Macron il vous donne une feuille de
route il vous dit bon ben j'attends que
vous fassiez 500 mes priorités c'est
cela
et là Emmanuel Macron me dit mais
comment voyez-vous les choses et alors
j'ai appris que je n'avais pas été
bénéficiaire d'un traitement particulier
et que c'était une phrase culte et à ce
moment-là le regard de le fameux regard
bleu glacier d'Emmanuel Macron se pose
sur vous il vous écoute avec une
intensité incroyable
et oui et c'est en cela que je dis c'est
pas l'attitude habituelle que j'ai
rencontré chez d'autres hommes
politiques que je ou femme d'ailleurs
avec qui j'ai travaillé et c'est en cela
qu'il est disruptif mais moi je suis du
vieux monde vous savez vous dites aussi
les idées bon ça l'intéressait pas trop
ce qui comptait c'était la personnalité
on se connaît pas moi je suis pas le
choix du président je suis ces gens
Castex qui proposent avec lesquels j'ai
travaillé sous Nicolas Sarkozy qu'il
était il a été conseillé social et
secrétaire général adjoint de l'Elysée
sous Nicolas et donc il me connaît pas
je ne le connais pas je le connais comme
en ouvrant les magazines et donc on
s'observe
la vous le dites votre feuille de route
pour vous c'était je serai la ministre
des artistes et des territoires alors
dans ce livre vous n'êtes pas tendre du
tout avec les élus locaux on va en
parler et vous parler notamment beaucoup
de la Décentralisation et des rapports
entre l'État et les collectivités et
vous vous êtes opposé à une nouvelle
phase de décentralisation vous dites
c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire c'est à
dire que nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation pourquoi pas mais en ce
qui concerne la culture je suis
extrêmement réticente sur une nouvelle
étape de la décentralisation parce que
nous sommes déjà à l'os si je puis dire
mais je sais bien que un certain nombre
d'élus locaux qui ont mis du temps à
s'approprier la question culturelle vous
savez moi je fais partie j'ai été élu
conseillère départemental on disait
général à l'époque en 82 j'ai donc fait
si on peut dire la décentralisation j'ai
été lu conseiller régional à 86 télé
premières élections
au Conseil régional au suffrage
universel j'ai donc vécu cette
décentralisation la culture intéressez
pas les élus locaux et puis ce sont
rendus compte petit à petit des
capacités de soft power que représentait
la culture je dis pas qu'il y avait pas
des actions culturelles mais il n'y
avait pas de politique culturelle et
maintenant
certains élus locaux voudraient
finalement transformer le ministère de
la Culture en une sorte d'agence de
conseil et prendre la main sur les
politiques culturelles moi je pense que
le rôle de l'État dans la culture est
éminent et que si on va plus loin en ce
qui concerne les politiques culturelles
on dépassera le ministère de la Culture
alors est-ce que pour autant je le dis
d'ailleurs dans le livre il ne faut pas
avancer sur des politiques de
contractualisation de partenariat je
n'imagine pas de ne pas faire les choses
avec les élus locaux et j'ai d'ailleurs
veillé à ce que toutes les décisions par
exemple les décisions de nomination soit
faite en partenariat en écoutant les
élus locaux et s'il y avait une je suis
allé vers des solutions de consensus
donc c'est pas une comment dirais-je
c'est pas une opposition c'est pas une
fracture mais je pense que là on peut
pas dépecer le ministère de la Culture
mais pas que sur la culture parce que
vous parlez aussi vous rappelez aussi
l'histoire des masques et dans beaucoup
de passages de votre livre vous dites en
gros les élus locaux ils veulent des
responsabilités mais ils les assume pas
on a l'impression que c'est un peu sale
message que vous voulez faire passer
dans ce livre je prends la loi l'exemple
de la loi du 13 août 2004 qui confie le
patrimoine non protégé à la
responsabilité des élus locaux et j'ai
le sentiment que voilà on peut pas se
contenter de demander du pouvoir et
ensuite de tendre la main vers l'état en
disant toujours plus d'argent il faut là
aussi prendre ses responsabilités sur la
protection du patrimoine j'ai rencontré
aussi beaucoup de difficultés avec
certains élus locaux bon j'ai essayé
d'apaiser les choses mais il y a aussi
un embrouille à min institutionnel qu'il
faut clarifier ça c'est très vrai vous
parlez justement du patrimoine vous en
parlez beaucoup dans votre livre alors
il y a une phrase qui a beaucoup fait
réagir c'est cette phrase qui concerne
les églises je la cite du truc contente
donc on en parle d'ici à 2050 ce sont
des dizaines de milliards qui seraient
nécessaires si nous voulons tout
conserver je suis désolé mais cela sera
impossible et il faudra beaucoup de
courage à mes successeur pour dire non
au sauvetage inconsidéré d'une église
sans intérêt patrimoniale mais à charge
émotionnelle et emblématique forte
est-ce que vous comprenez que cette
phrase est fait réagir mais oui je
comprends
mais moi je dis la vérité
il y a un article très intéressant dans
les échos ce matin
où on demande aux Français
imaginons que vous ayez une cagnotte de
plusieurs dizaines de milliards dont
vous pouviez et que vous pouviez en
faire quelque chose et franchement cette
les réponses m'ont fait de la peine
parce que on le désendettement de l'État
les retraites la santé l'éducation très
bien il y a pas un mot pour la culture
il y a pas un Français qui souhaite
combattre plus d'argent dans la culture
et les Français répondent d'une certaine
façon
à cela moi ceci ça que je dis devant les
enjeux qui sont sur les bâtiments
culturels les églises mais il y a
d'autres bâtiments que les églises les
temples les synagogues les mosquées les
chapelles les oratoires les couvents les
pardons les bons ça va demander un
argent considérable les propriétés
aristocratiques
je constate que là où le l'héritier
devenait un gentilhomme compagnat
campagnard et reprenait le château de
ses ancêtres il est maintenant banquier
à Singapour bon il y a un abandon
considérable et tout ça ce sont des
dizaines de milliards moi ce que je dis
si on ne change pas de maquette
budgétaire aussi bien l'État les
collectivités territoriales et les
mécènes mécène aussi bien mais scènes
des grandes entreprises ou des grands
donateurs que le mécène a populaire on y
arrivera pas et c'est ça que je dis je
suis content d'avoir lancé en quelque
sorte cette grenade si ça pouvait en
réveiller certains qui tiennent à leurs
églises et bien écoutez
vous l'avez peut-être lui dit chaque
église détruite est un aveu d'échec mais
il a raison je partage cet avis je dis
simplement
il va falloir trouver des fonds
considérables et d'une certaine la même
façon on voit bien que c'est formidable
on lui a confié la mission patrimoine
avec le loto du patrimoine mais on est
sur des sommes je veux pas dire ridicule
mais sur quelques dizaines de millions
d'euros alors que le défi il est à
plusieurs milliards et à plusieurs
dizaines de milliards donc
je dis à Stéphane tu as tout à fait
raison détruire une église sera un échec
mais allez on se retrouve sur les
manches et autres et on trouve l'argent
quand on lit votre livre alors il n'y a
pas que les églises qui tombent en
ruines il y a aussi les préfectures vous
racontez quand vous étiez ministre
évidemment vous allez dormir dans des
préfectures ce qui visiblement n'était
pas le cas de tous vos collègues et R
vous nous décrivez des préfectures ça
donne pas franchement envie de dire le
patrimoine de l'État étant étant grand
danger parce que en général les grandes
institutions d'abord les ministères pour
commencer le ministère de la Culture qui
est installé au palais royal mais
d'autres
encore le patrimoine de l'État étant
très grande difficulté et derrière les
salons qui font encore un peu illusion
on est dans en grande déshérence mais
c'est la même chose pour un certain
nombre d'institutions qui sont logés
dans ces palais de la République le
public pense que on est sous les ordres
des campus les portes c'est pas c'est
pas utile
sanitaire entartré literie défoncé c'est
effectivement je pense que encore je
pense que ce sont dans les préfectures
dans ce qu'on appelle la chambre
ministre qu'on trouve encore des
télévisions à tube cathodique vous
parlez aussi aussi très vite dans ce
livre
est-ce que vous dites vous allez dans un
hôtel il y avait certains préfets oh non
non madame la mini sont à vous je serai
dans la chambre ministre vous parlez
aussi très rapidement dans ce livre des
festivals et les festivals en ce moment
dans le pays ils sont très inquiets
après les déclarations de Gérald
Darmanin qui dit qu'il sera difficile
d'assurer la sécurité des Jeux
Olympiques et celle des festivals à
l'été 2024 et que donc il pourrait être
menacé reporté voire annuler est-ce
qu'il faut avoir peur que ces festivals
soient sacrifiés sur lequel des choses
je pense que il y a des craintes
extrêmement sérieuses je sais que ma
successeur imabdoumalaq a reçu les les
les organisateurs de festival et qu'elle
s'emploie à cela mais là aussi vous
savez moi j'ai regardé ce qui s'était
passé
au Stade de France lors du fameux match
Real Liverpool et où on a mobilisé 8000
policiers et avec les échecs on a
rencontré les difficultés dans les
mouvements de population on va être sur
une autre une autre dimension rien que
la la cérémonie d'ouverture sur la scène
va regrouper plusieurs millions de
personnes
je sais que d'ores et déjà tous les tous
les congés d'été ont été supprimés pour
tous les policiers de France
je sais que je serai organisateur de
festival des grands festivals de musique
actuelle oh le festival de musique
baroque qui regroupe 150 personnes dans
une église romane de ma circonscription
ne sera pas menacé par les Jeux
Olympiques parce que c'est ça aussi le
tissu des festivals il y a pas seulement
les les grands festivals de musique
actuelle comme les Vieilles Charrues ou
d'autres mais il y a aussi tout ce tissu
qui irrigue la vie culturelle et c'est
formidable mais sur des grand festival
on pense aussi à des festivals de
théâtre comme Avignon ou des festivals
de musique comme Aix-en-Provence ou
comme Orange ou évidemment regroupe
plusieurs milliers plusieurs pour les
musiques actuelles plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes il est évident
qu'au moment de des Jeux Olympiques on
aura du mal à assurer la sécurité donc
il faudra soit déplacer soit peut-être
annuler enfin
actuellement il y a aussi une polémique
sur un festival en Occitanie les
déferlantes des artistes Louise Attaque
Indochine ont refusé de se produire à
Perpignan qui est la plus grande ville
du rassemblement national parce qu'elle
était dirigée par l'Assemblée nationale
vous les comprenez je voulais comprendre
oui tout à fait et puis c'est la
responsabilité d'un artiste que d'être
un citoyen et je
ne refuse absolument pas je ne réfute
absolument pas les artistes qui prennent
des positions politiques s'ils sont ils
sont aussi dans leur rôle c'est pas du
sectarisme comme le dit par exemple
David Lisnard le président de
l'Association des maires de France
est-ce que c'est aux habitants de ces
villes d'être privés de ce genre de
festival parce que la ville est dirigée
par le rassemblement national non mais
de toute façon il y a toute possibilité
d'avoir accès à la culture je crois
qu'il faut pas opposer le public et les
artistes les artistes ont le droit de
s'exprimer et le public de prendre ses
responsabilités
être ministre c'est aussi se frotter au
parlementaire c'est ce que vous racontez
dans votre livre et vous parler
notamment du Sénat on va regarder un
petit extrait de vos auditions au Sénat
lorsque vous étiez ministre
comment ça se passe il y a une salle de
question je réponds question après des
quatre rapports
on vous laissera répondre à cette
première série de questions et puis
après toujours sur la mission
médias et industrie culturelle celles et
ceux qui veulent s'exprimer le feront
dans un second temps beaucoup de
beaucoup de questions toutes
intéressantes mais je sais j'attends vos
questions je ne doute pas qu'elle
permettront de payer mon propos
liminaire qui est forcément incomplet
mais vous allez m'aider à le compléter
c'est compliqué pour un ministre de
venir devant le Sénat vous parlez de
questions posées avec le ton d'où serait
battant des prédateurs qui guettent
leurs proies
donc je les ai pas mal à l'aise au
contraire j'ai beaucoup de jouissance à
être devant les devants les
parlementaires mais c'est vrai que j'ai
été confronté à une petite difficulté
c'est que je suis nommé ministre le 6
juillet et le 8 juillet je suis le
premier jour de mon exercice je suis
devant le Sénat et sur un texte ce qu'on
appelle la loi d'adules et diverses
dispositions
qui concerne l'audiovisuel et il y a des
très grands spécialistes de
l'audiovisuel au Sénat je dirais même
je suis ton répètera pas l'Assemblée
nationale mais meilleur qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale je pense à des gens comme
David Assouline comme Catherine Morin de
saillie à l'époque il y avait monsieur
il y a vraiment des gens très costauds
et vous êtes là quelques heures après
votre nomination et vous devez avaler un
dossier heureusement que je j'ai
l'habitude de ce genre de ce genre
d'exercice mais c'est toujours fait sur
un mode très patelin très technique et
j'ai toujours eu l'impression d'être
devant le lion vous savez dans la savane
qui est avec ses papas de croisées
attends attends sa proie mais c'était un
peu un jeu
très très bon je le disais en début
d'interview vous parlez aussi de votre
ancienne famille politique dans ce livre
les républicains et vous parlez du
profond des arois selon vous qui sévit
dans la droite modérée des républicaine
minée par les querelles de personnes et
les scandales financiers mais surtout
incapables de conduire une ligne
idéologique cohérente et un programme
opérationnel et vous racontez même un
jour vous êtes retrouvé de votre devant
vos anciens camarades de républicains et
vous dites on est même pas en Ligue 2 on
est en National 3 c'est c'est sévère
quand même c'est un problème alors ok
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus global et qui
touche pas seulement la famille des
républicains il faut dire que il y a
certains nombres de phénomènes qui se
sont passés l'interdiction du cumul des
mandats à priver la classe politique
d'un vivier
je le reconnais je me suis planté j'ai
été contre le cumul des mandats c'est
une erreur j'en demande pardon à ceux
qui à l'époque me prévenaient de ce qui
allait se passer bon première chose il y
avait ce vivier dans ton a été privé il
y a eu le sentiment aussi qu'il y avait
une sorte de fliquage de mise en cause
et politique et un certain nombre de
gens de qualité ne veulent plus ne
veulent plus faire de politique il y a
eu et effectivement alors bien sûr il
rémunération qui sont très convenables
mais comparé à ce qui peut être fait
dans le privé très inférieur à ce qui
peut être dans le privé pour un niveau
de responsabilité comparable la crête
aussi ne pas pouvoir retrouver son son
métier puisque si on prend un expert
dans son métier sur un poste technique
il pourra pas l'exercer à la sortie donc
tout ça fait qu'il y a une sorte de
déperdition de de l'attractivité de la
fonction politique et c'est vrai que
quand je revois mon entrée à l'Assemblée
nationale en 88 et d'avoir devant moi
Jacques Chirac Édouard Balladur Alain
Juppé Jacques Toubon Philippe Seguin
Charles Pasqua Michel Alliot-Marie
Michel Barzac on avait des monstres on
avait des stars et ce type de politique
a disparu
on va terminer en parlant de la fin de
votre livre et puis vous vous racontez
alors que la France attendait le nom de
son futur premier ministre vous aussi un
temps interminable
et vous finissez par envoyer un SMS
Emmanuel Macron lui si je rentre nommé
Elisabeth borne
c'est vrai que le président a joué avec
nous alors moi ça me concernait pas
puisque Ben décision était prise mais 4
semaines d'attente je me souvenais de la
du 2e mandat de Jacques Chirac il était
lu le lendemain le lundi le 1er ministre
est nommé le mardi le gouvernement est
constitué et le le secrétaire général
adjoint puisque le secrétaire général
rentrait au gouvernement le secrétaire
général adjoint que vous connaissez bien
puisqu'il s'appelait Philippe Bas
annonce le gouvernement tout ça est fait
très vite et là pendant quatre semaines
j'ai d'ailleurs beaucoup ri parce que
à non nouveau de ministre de la Culture
surgissait dans mon bureau les noms les
plus approbables et c'était c'était une
sorte de comédien del arte alors
j'envoie un message au Président je dis
la meilleure votre meilleur choix serait
Élisabeth ban c'était évidemment je dis
Roselyne qui se mêle de skin l'affaire
et pour rire après la nomination
d'Elizabeth borne il m'avait il m'a dit
vous voyez je vous écoute mais je suis
c'est une femme de très de très grande
qualité Elisabeth rugueuse parfois mais
profondément humaine elle a les épaules
pour assumer ce qui arrive et notamment
la réforme des retraites elle a vraiment
les épaules on va on va terminer par
votre départ forcément de la rue de
Valois et toutes vos affaires tiennent
dans deux petits cartons et vous dites
c'est un conseil de mon père voilà mon
père me disait pratique la cesse de
l'adieu dans toutes les fonctions que tu
occuperas n'apporte aucun personnel
aucune photo qu'un bibelot tu dois
quitter son ton bureau tous les soirs
comme si tu ne devais jamais y revenir
merci Roselyne Bachelot merci beaucoup
d'être venu nous parler de votre livre
plein d'anecdotes évidemment
passionnante votre récit et puis
également une réflexion de fond sur
l'avenir de la culture dans ce livre
merci beaucoup d'être venu nous en
parler on remonte 682 jours c'est aux
éditions plombs merci on passe au club
des territoires